Hello, everybody. Doug Walker here,
and welcome to The Last Airbender V-Logs.
As you can tell this was actually shot right after I did the intro,
so I have seen the very first episode:
uh, "The Boy in the Iceberg".
And, uh,
First impressions, I guess.
'cuz, it's interesting a lot of people say
"Once you watch it you're really gonna be, like, sucked in
and you wanna see more and more and more."
I don't know if this started off as like a movie, where they run some of the episodes together.
And the first episode is very good, and it's very creative.
I will admit, it didn't-
It didn't suck me in like something like Lost or Game of Thrones did,
but, then again,
It is a Nickolodeon show.
Which everyone says like,
"Oh, no this totally changes, you know, like the way Nickolodeon shows look."
And I believe it,
'cuz it is a very impressive looking show.
What did sort of, uh, throw me-
I don't wanna say "throw me for a loop", and it's not totally fair to say this, but,
And maybe it's a good thing and bad thing is that
watching the first episode I had to sort of remind myself:
"Oh, yeah, this is for kids."
I think there's something about the design and even kinda the pacing and the layout,
Where it sort of fools you into almost thinking, like:
"Oh, yeah this is a movie."
You know there's this scene where they're looking inside this uh, looks like a submarine,
and it's very quiet.
And they've got these great angles,
and there's no talking and no music you just hear the echoes of the ship,
and,
it'll be interesting, from here on to see
if this is, like,
see if the rest of the show goes like this.
And of course, a lot of you probably already know,
but as someone just coming in,
I was impressed by it,
and I think somebody also going in
with a lot of hype behind it,
is probably not the best way to go in, I realize,
because, automatically you're going to be like:
"Well, that first episode didn't totally pull me in."
and stuff like that, but again,
It's a series and it's an intro.
Uhh...
And, you know, for an intro, it was very interesting, and...
Literally as it begins, it says like, you know,
"The four nations, the Fire Nations, the Earth Nations, the... Heart Nations -"
I'm sure everybody's made that joke.
Um, but...
They're given this back story, and at first I'm thinking:
"Oh my god, are kids going to be able to follow this?
This is, like, a lot to take in."
And then immediately goes to,
uh, you know, the brother and sister who are making jokes,
and, you know, they sort of sound-
the brother especially is a bit of a wise cracker, and stuff,
and I start going, "Oh yeah. That's right. Kid's show."
But,
Again, that's the balance.
That's what you gotta put up with, I realize.
And, I like the fact that, um,
They sound like kids, the brother not quite so much,
maybe he's a teenager, but-
but these sound like real kids.
And I don't know if they're played by adults or not,
but they do a good job.
and I think what grabbed me the most,
or what I found the most interesting.
Outside the designs and the backgrounds, those are looking wonderful,
uh, is the animation itself. And the animation is very much,
obviously anime influenced, to a point where people could probably confuse it for anime,
but you can definitely tell it's American.
And there is something about American motion and Japanese motion that is very different,
'cuz Japanese motion seems to be,
they put all their animation into the action, I mean, like, ALL OF IT.
And then the rest of it is like,
you know, there's a lot of close ups like this, of someone talking and looking at something,
you don't see the mouth moving,
because all the animation went into the action.
But what's so clever about it is that they hide it very well
by getting very stylized shots and stylized angles.
American animation is much more about the motion.
So here you have them constantly...
Constantly in motion,
though, it's interesting 'cuz you could probably see where some arguments came up,
particularly in the humour,
because, like when somebody is shocked by something,
usual American animation will do, like, three frames of a person, "huh?"
Like that. Where a Japanese animation would just have a person here, and then the next frame he's here.
So...
And you see that happen here a few times,
Like when eyes open up, it's not like, you know, a frame or two of them opening up.
It's just open.
Uh...
And that's a stylistic choice,
I know that's just part of Japanese animation.
So, it's an interesting balance.
This is probably, so far, uh...
One of the more interesting balances between, sorta the Japanese style and the American style,
that I've seen, not that I've seen much... Nickelodeon/anime imitation shows.
Uh...
Okay, for example, I did see a little bit of that show Teen Titans,
And...
Not the newer one, whatever the...
whatever the one that came out like, what, five, six years ago. Something like that, maybe even older.
Uh, came out, and that was obviously trying to, you know, mimic anime.
Uh, with all the big, over-the-top stuff,
and the big sweat drop and stuff like that.
I can't stand that.
And I know that's a style. If you like it, great.
It drives me insane.
This is a lot- This is a nice medium.
I like the medium that they have here.
Sometimes, the comedy's a little awkward,
Uh, again, maybe 'cuz I'm just not used to...
That really quick animation, maybe I'll warm up to it.
Um...
But so far it's an interesting intro,
and it has a lot of mystery behind it.
It gives you the backstory but at the same time,
You know, what exactly is the story behind this prince guy?
And why are the Fire... Why is the Fire Nation a bunch of A-holes?
and why are they looking to take over?
and, you know, how is the war going?
I like stories where something really big is going on...
Out there, some sort of big battle,
and yet, the, you know,
identifiable characters, the young people,
are off somewhere, and they want to help, and they can't,
you know, until something comes along to...
throw them in there, but it's not...
It's not quite hammered in as much as,
You know, a lot of other shows and movies like to do it.
Um...
And the fact that is a show allows so much more time,
you know, like...
I don't know are they gonna- are they gonna go to the North Pole?
Is that the next episode?
I mean, I like- I like not knowing anything about this show going in.
Uh...
So with that said, I don't know how many of the comments I'm going to read,
'cuz I know some people may give it away.
And I want you guys to feel free to, you know, comment and talk about it.
Um
But, uh, the last thing I'll say before I sign off here is the, uh,
Uh, about the first episode is the...
You know, I was talking about the designs. I love the animals in this.
I've only seen, I think, two now.
One is a giant flying bison.
Which, just, props for creativity, man
that is fucking weird.
And the other is,
which I find this so strange, they're penguins.
They just say they're penguins, but they're...
Clearly not regular "panguin"-
Penguins.
They look like a mix between penguins and otters,
and they sled on them, and I like that.
I like that they sort of create a world that's similar to ours,
but it's also one that they can kind of interact in, in their own way.
Even the, uh, Avatar boy, he seems very...
Instead of getting up using his legs or, you know, or whatever, standing up,
he can just use his power, the wind power just to sort of...
have the wind push him up.
I love little touches like that.
Or there's this scene where the girl gets really angry,
and she accidentally bends the water, uh, behind her and cracks it,
and isn't even aware she does it.
Little things like that, those are great touches.
And I think it makes a world much more believable and livable.
And maybe that's one of the big attractions about the show, I dunno, I'll have to see.
But, uh,
It was a good first episode- and of course,
Finally get to see Mako ("may-ko"), I know it's "mah-ko", but everyone's called him "may-ko",
so I'm just gonna stick to that, 'cuz that's the joke now, I guess.
Um.
Finally see him as the prince's, uh- is that his uncle?
I dunno, I'm sure a lot of you are gonna chew me up for it.
Um...
But,
And yeah, boy, something about...
'Cuz this is the show everyone, when I first made the Mako joke,
everybody said, "That's the guy from Avatar, come on, come on."
And it is interesting, 'cuz he sounds so different,
from, something like when he did Splinter in the Ninja Turtles Movie.
Uh, something about that, sounded a little bit more slurred, and sort of like half awake.
And in this one he sounds very...
He sounds very dignified.
And, you know, like a warrior who's been through a lot, but...
Still has a good sorta sense of humour, too, so I'm...
Even just seeing a few bits of that character, I see what people sort of admired about his performance,
'cuz I can already hear it, I'm like,
"This guy's... Like is probably the most interesting character so far."
I just want to know what his story is,
and you already feel, sorta that conflict of, you know,
should he help this prince, should he, sort of,
you know, make a compromise with his teachings, or should he...
You know, really stick to what he knows is right,
but,  you know, time is of the essence and lives are at stake, and..
It's good stuff.
So...
I know it's a lot to say just for the first episode, but uh...
It's interesting. Um...
If I didn't...
I will make- If I didn't have the hype around it, I don't know if I'd be like,
"I HAVE to see the next episode!"
Uh...
But I do want to see the next episode, out of curiosity.
I want to know where it goes.
I like this kid, I like the sister.
He's a little weird.
Um...
I'll just have to see if he gets better.
But, um,
Yeah, so I'll look forward to see where it goes.
Uh, that's episode one. I'll see you for episode two!